ça y est je crois que j'ai la réponse à
la question pourquoi tant de haine face
aux dinosaures sans plume de jurassic
world c'est parce que même dans
transformers 4
il n'avait pas osé ne pas mettre de
plumes sur les dinosaures michael bay a
mis des plumes sur ces dinosaures et pas
jurassique world
regardez où tout début de transformers 4
il y à un psittacose or c'est un
dinosaure herbivore un ornithischiens
même pas un velociraptor et il a des
plumes à peu près là où on les a
découverts justement sur le fossile
maintenant regardez jurassic park
transformers 4 en accord avec son époque
en retard complet de plus de 20 en un
seul de ces deux films à la prétention
de revendiquer un background
scientifique l'autre se veut simplement
et puis